hello everyone and welcome to a truly
spectacular game from the elimination
round of the american cup it's wesley
saw versus levon arunan and so many of
you guys have requested this again for
very good reasons it's um
one of those games where you really have
no idea what a piece is worth because
when you're a child that they will teach
you like a pawn is worth one maybe a
knight is worth three bishop is worth
three okay maybe in modern times we're
gonna give bishop a value of maybe three
and a third just because it's supposed
to be a little bit better than a knight
but then again you've seen positions
where a bishop completely dominates a
knight and you've seen positions where a
knight completely dominates the bishop
then we're going to attribute let's say
five points to a rook we're going to
attribute 10 points to a queen or in
modern times maybe nine and a half as
two rooks should be better than a queen
but then again you've seen positions
where two rooks completely dominate the
queen and you've seen positions where a
queen completely dominates a rook and
here by move 30 we're gonna have three
queens on the board
which kind of means that okay the player
that has two queens obviously wins the
game easily uh but this is just another
game that shows you how amazing chess is
and why we have been so infatuated with
the game for for so many centuries and
if you are wondering why meadow is not
present in this video uh there is a fish
being cooked downstairs and he refuses
to leave the the fish alone so he just
sits there and you know he he enjoys the
the
i guess the smell and the sound of the
fish uh in case you were wondering now
getting back to the game uh wesley has
the white pieces and again we're going
to have a very very exciting nimzo
indian defense so d4 uh knight to f6 c
for e6 knight to c3 and bishop to b4
levon goes for the names of indian
defense and here wesley tackles it with
e3 so the standard and modern approach
we always mention that queen c2 and e3
are the most popular replies white has
nowadays uh castles and now bishop to d2
this is somewhat rare but again
it has been played many times
you don't uh play some like queen to c2
uh so when black finally captures on c3
you don't have to mess up your pawn
structure but you will not be capturing
with the queen you will be capturing
with the bishop and you will have your
bishop on a very nice diagonal so here
c5 uh we have a3 now challenging the
bishop and the bishop captures on c3
bishop captures and now knight to e4
challenging the bishop on c3 and also
this is a beautiful square for the
knight if white wants to kick it away
he's gonna have to play something like
knight v2 knight g3 or maybe even f3 in
the future but we're gonna have a
beautiful knight on e4 we're gonna play
b6 bishop to b7 put a bishop on this
diagonal play f5 consolidate even
further and those are some general ideas
so here obviously goes knight to e2 this
is the
standard way b6 preparing to fianchetto
the bishop and now wesley says all right
d5 you are not getting this diagonal for
your bishop uh we have d6 by levon and
now uh f3 and queen to c2 are moves that
have been played in this position
challenging the knight here but wesley
plays rook to c1 and it is now as of
move tender we have a completely new
game so what does levon do he plays e5
and uh already you can see that uh it
will be somewhat problematic to develop
this bishop you can't really put it on
b7 anymore on on a6 okay
it might serve some purpose but uh it's
very hard to
uh to imagine it actually going there uh
so we'll see what levon comes up with we
have knight the g3 a challenging in the
night here and now knight captures on c3
we have capture so wesley doesn't have
to mess up his pawn structure and now
the bishop and the rook will support the
advancement of the f pawn so pawn to f5
and now bishop to d3 uh asking levon is
he interested in advancing the pawn even
further levon says yes that is exactly
what i'm interested in bishop to c2 and
now look at this beautiful e5 square
it's a
spectacular knight
outpost for our knight so knight to d7
the knight is now coming to e5 and white
will have some problems dislodging it
from there so here we have castles by
wesley and knight to e5 and here uh what
do you play well this wesley goes for a
pawn to b4 uh it's not a not a
bad move uh but black's position is just
better so uh no move that white can make
here will make his position better so uh
why not b4 uh and here okay you could
consider something like bishop to a6
levon went from for immediate rook to f6
but here bishop to a6 uh might actually
not be a bad idea we force white to
advance the pawn and then we bring the
bishop back we completely close the
queen side the the century is closed and
now we completely shift our attention
towards the king side to attack with the
moves like queen h4 rook f6 rook h6 f4
uh and so on uh but okay uh we have to
keep in mind this is a rapid game rook
to f6 and now wesley says all right i
don't really have a way of entangling
here uh let's just go uh and play f4 uh
so what do you do here uh if you go
knight g4 h3 and you really don't have
any good squares for this knight so
everyone just captures this alpha song
we have e captures on f3 g captures on
f3 of course as the knight is guarding
the f3 square and now wesley has a bit
more room to breed but he opened his
king a little bit so f4 leveling wants
to further open up the position plus he
opens up this diagonal for his light
square bishop knight to h5 attacking the
rook and then now comes the immediate
bishop to h3 and this is probably not a
square you had in mind when uh the this
diagonal got close to where the uh black
slide square brush will be developed
and here wesley plays e captures on f4
now it's a very very crazy position so
i'm just going to show you how crazy it
really is because the only good move for
wasteless day is to capture the rook on
f6 with check queen captures now e
captures on f4 challenging the knight
and after bishop captures on f1 we play
f captures on e5 queen captures on e5
and now we have to of course our rook
here is hanging so we don't have time to
pick up the bishop but what we can play
is give up our bishop and after king h7
queen captures an f1 uh complete madness
of course for a rapid game you don't
have time to calculate this and now of
course you can see that the rook is
hanging but if the rook is captured then
wesley can get a very nice draw king g8
queen to e6 check and you will always be
able to check the black king uh
along this diagonal and of course if he
goes to f8 then you're going to capture
this if he goes further
to the queen side then you're going to
deliver check pick up the rook and then
it's white who's going to be better so
instead after a bishop to h3 west plate
e captures an f4 which is a move that
definitely uh is a part of this line
however not in this particular order uh
and levon now uh uh plays rook to h6 he
puts pressure on the knight here and we
have f captures on e5 and now levon
plays bishop captures on f1 rook
captures on h5 was a little bit better
uh as it keeps all the pressure the
queen is coming to g5 the other rook is
coming to a fade with bishop captures on
f1 he allows wesley to get back into the
game uh he wesley plays knight g3 goes
after the bishop save he saves his
knight from h5 bishop to h3 and now e6
and here okay uh almost looks like levon
is the one who's in trouble because
wesley now has a uh protected pass pawn
on e6 uh but okay queen to g5 we get our
queen into the attack b captures in c5b
captures on c5 and now queen to e1 uh
preparing to further advance the pawn so
levon plays rook to f8 and now wesley
finds the beautiful f4 the idea being
that if for example queen captures then
you play e7 and the queen no longer has
any uh pressure on this uh e7 pawn
because if it did you would play rook
eight and then you would already have a
queen and the rook attacking the pawn
but now after rook eight bishop a4
attacks the rook on e8 uh it's not going
to be easy for black so instead we have
queen the h4 uh leaving that pawn b uh
and now wesley plays queen to e2 queen
the e3 was a uh much much safer but
wesley goes for queen to e2 and now
levon plays queen captures on f4 e7
challenging the rook here and now queen
to d4 with check we have king to h1 and
now queen captures on c3 so he picks up
the rook on c3 and now what can westley
play if you play e captures on f8 and
okay bring a queen into the game we're
gonna capture with a king and there's
really no good way to continue this with
white black is just better and pretty
much completely winning if let's say
queen f2 check you can easily block with
the rook and then you are really in
trouble so what levon does is he brings
another queen into the game and this is
now move 30 and we already have three
queens on the board and of course uh um
kyle levon can't just pick this up
because queen capture 78 will be
checkmate so what can levon play here
well he starts with rook to f6
puts more pressure along the f file
because you can see the bishop guarding
f1 and both of the rooks now eyeing that
f1 square if white isn't careful
a nice checkmate might be in order so
here we have
queen back to e4 uh getting the queen
out of harm's way because now the rook
is on f6 so you could capture the queen
and defend checkmate with this rook but
now uh here queen captures an h7 is
being threatened so it seems like wesley
came up on top uh you know of all of
this mess but queen to a1 with check and
now you can't block with uh anything
like this because if knight f1 we can
just capture this queen captures an f1
and after queen captures rook captures
on f1 will be checkmate so instead after
queen to a1 we have bishop to b1 again
preventing uh blocking check while still
threatening queen captures on h7 and is
there anything left for levon to do here
well he will defend checkmate with g6
and now
uh well
at the end of the day it's a wesley who
has the two queens and we already said
that queen is worth uh 10 points or
maybe nine and a half so he's definitely
up in material uh but here we have queen
to e1
a very nice move now the bishop can also
also move uh but now queen b2 levon now
threatens um uh well he keeps an eye on
the b and the g2 square and you have to
be very very careful of what you do
and best way uh to do this is uh well
there just is no good way if you play
something like queen back here we're
gonna capture and after queen captures
again rook to f1 will result in
checkmate not in checkmate but for
example after rook captures queen
captures and bishop captures this is now
a completely winning endgame for for
lavon he's the pawn and also white's
position is very very passive the the
pawn here is attacked you're gonna have
to play bishop to a2 to defend it and
now white the bishop is very passive and
you're just going to start bringing your
king into the game put a king on e5
start pushing the pawns create a pass
pawn here and uh white will be unable to
uh stop all of this plus these pawns are
on dark square so white really doesn't
have any targets for the bishop
so after queen to b2 bishop to d3 was
played now it seems like okay we added
another piece to guard the f1 square and
now we have rook to f4 rook to f3 was
even better but uh you know it's a rapid
game that these guys really don't have
all that much time rook to f4 was played
uh and now wesley gets this queen to e2
move now he offers a queen trade and
levon goes back queen to f6 so he puts
all the pressure he has on that f1
square and the wesley is defending that
f1 square with everything he has uh and
here
the position is actually uh equal but
wesley has to spot queen e7 after queen
e7 uh for example you're gonna go queen
back to b2 you're gonna threaten
checkmate and we're just gonna repeat
queen to e2 where now okay lemon can
either repeat or he can play queen
captures an a3 and only then king to g1
and now okay the game continues however
after queen to f6 by the one wesley
played the immediate king to g1 and this
will simply not to do this allows lavon
to perform a beautiful beautiful
combination uh queen to d4 with check
and okay it doesn't look like much we're
just gonna uh block this we have queen
to e3 and now uh there is only one move
that wins the game for levon and it is
the one move that wesley missed uh so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for levon while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
queen on e3 can't really move as uh well
it's pinned and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is rook
to e8 that's correct we pile up on the
white queen and it was in this position
on move 37 that uh wesley so resigned
the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
it's a beautiful beautiful position
where anything wesley does results in a
in a very very uh abrupt checkmate so
just to give you uh an example if queen
captures on d4 we're going to play rook
captures on e1 and now you have to block
bishop to f1 we're gonna play rook
captures on f1 knight captures and the
rook captures on f1 will be checkmate uh
so there's that and on the other hand if
you don't capture the queen well what do
you do
because we are just threatening to win
all the queens here and then checkmate
the white king so you might play
something like knight to f1
but now pretty much anything is winning
for the one we can play rook captures on
f1 and after sorry after bishop captures
on f1 we're going to play rook captures
on e3 so now we're threatening all sorts
of nasty discoveries uh via the queen on
d4 we just moved the rook and if queen
to f2 it seems like wesley again has
defended successfully but now comes the
absolute shocker rook to e1
i mean wow
uh so the thread is real captures on f1
this will be checkmate and there is
nothing wesley can do about this of
course the queen will not be able to
capture back the queen is pinned by the
queen on d4 and again if you capture the
queen on d4 then rook captures on d1 is
again checkmate
so brilliant brilliant stuff both of
them played extremely well uh wesley uh
bounced back from some very very uh
difficult positions and he even got a
beautiful passport he got a second queen
into the game he got to keep the second
queen uh but it simply wasn't enough so
here yeah just another game that really
shows you that even though we sometimes
attribute value to the pieces and pawns
like you know one three three a three
and a third five or maybe nine and a
half or a ten for a queen uh this is all
uh
the the this should always be uh viewed
as a as a potential not as an actual uh
strength of a piece throughout the
entire game so while your queen can be
worth 10 points it can also be worth one
or zero points as you've seen in this
game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh thank you always for
suggesting such wonderful games uh i
would like to thank andrew dabrowski
kirsten lehmann's uh guy lefleus course
uh dk benjamin and demarco galaxy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions such as this
one and whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day